you're so good hi everyone my name is
Tamara chambers hello everyone my name
is Taylor chambers and this is Tamara
Jessa we're in our childhood home for
Christmas this is where the next to
Tamra is just saw videos are gonna be so
great there's also no microphone it's
gonna be so fun in our kitchen in our
kitchen looking we're also going to be
doing an episode of Tamra's never seen
with my parents and if you're following
me on Twitter I will be posting out a
thing
opening up to questions to my parents
about why I never saw anything so get
ready for that as well but today we saw
too much
drew water I think there's gonna be
spoilers in this it's a movie where it's
like then the spoilers aren't crazy only
Nick Jonas is you can expect the plot
yeah it's not that's going to be
complicated it just it's just what it is
is very good it's not horribly like
twisted like layers story it's like you
know what's going on you know what's
like who's doing what and it's but it's
fine it's a lot of fun it's yeah it's
the fun feel-good family film of the
Christmas season I feel like I am was
going in with crazy low expectations
I laughed throughout the entire thing I
got emotional at the end even though
it's cheesy I was still like there that
got me you got me
yeah it was hit hard what really I
wanted more of though is them explaining
how Jumanji got into a video game versus
a board game I had a dear guy that I was
thinking
yeah yeah I was like okay so what did to
monji is more like a spirit that kind of
manifests as a game but like it has to
like adapt sorta to like you know keep
keep its influence so I guess it had to
like read like resurrect in some way you
missed the beginning because I told
Taylor to go to the wrong theater my
fault oh yeah the very like first like
10 minutes yeah and they they show and
that's exactly what happened the dad
gives the little boy a war games like
what am I gonna do with board games it's
the 90s and he's playing video games and
the Jumanji sees that he's playing video
games turns into a video game cartridge
and then starts throwing the drum beats
and then he's like oh dude is a video
game and the money dude I wish that
there's a little bit more of that it
seems like that was like the cheesiest
part to me that it was just like the
very convenient well there's no story
here it's just the Jumanji is now a
video game but it's about these four
children who these two or high schoolers
who get detention and they're in this
old part of the school organizing
magazines for detention and it's just
like way better than just sitting there
which is most attention anyways they
find gog and play it and they choose
their characters they are their
characters and that's where the most fun
comes in is the character assignments in
the game and those throughout the whole
movie as the rock is a scrawny nerd and
then Karen Gillian is another very nerdy
girl who's just not like confident with
boys Kevin Hart is played he's a short
man as we all know and he the kid that
she's having heart as a very tall very
muscular football player and then the
best one by far even though they're all
very good is a popular blonde a little
ditzy phone obsessed self-obsessed
teenage girl is Jack Black and it's so
funny I think this might be my favorite
role that I've seen Jack Black
you would think the big gets tired it
has like low bits but it's pretty good
they keep it fresh they don't just do
the same thing yeah I really enjoy also
the aspects that they bring into it of
being a video game I feel like they did
that less in the first Jumanji cuz I
mean what kind of like board games ropes
are there were there there's so much you
could do with video games and I was also
expecting to go in and be like man I
wish they would have just gone even
further with that I think they could
have but I feel like for a general
audience who's more gamers so like for a
general audience for a lot of you who
aren't gamers it's just gamer e-enough
and it's like oh I know that there's
lives like things like that where is
like if they went to into it like it
would be cool for like gamers but rug I
think it was the perfect amount and and
it came in in really funny ways he's
really clever yeah it was clever also
something that I loved is that the CGI
there was a few moments when they were
in the video game where the background
looked a very CGI like just a couple
shots but they're in a video game yes
and that really works well I wrote some
news really see what a brute I wrote
Jack Black is a goddess yes Jack Black
this is my favorite jack honest to god
he's so good he's just living his best
way also the other big player and this
is Nick Jonas oh he shows up I thought
he was delightful not super funny but
his character wasn't really written
funny it's always nice to see the Jonas
Brothers pop up now I didn't have man
well what's the one of their songs
oh the year 2000 the head it was just
like that yeah
is a badass man killer in the game and
one of her special skills is dance
fighting there's a lot of keys that I
just want to ology bitch she's my last
note is so touching at the end what the
duck because I was in a theater and I
was trying not to flash my phone in it
who would you care dude I thought Dwayne
the rock Johnson killed it dude yeah I
always enjoy watching him she was really
good in this he was he's such
he's a dynamic actor where you just you
go in feeling like every time I see that
he's in a movie I'm like oh I like him
but it's just cuz he's fun but then
you're like no no no he's he's very good
this movie had incredible casting just
across the board so strong the kids were
also really well cast but you see mostly
just the adults in the video game land I
did not plan on liking it nearly as much
as I did no and I'm so happy I saw
[Music]
alright bye yeah 313
well yeah it's pg-13 because the way
they did allowed that it was it was
foreign like a general audience which I
thought was cool you could have made it
like really intense and like your face
and like God's gonna kill you and like
gory and all that may like are it's like
but it it was you know it really just
wanted to have like it's just fun it
wanted to be a fun movie and so like the
comedy elements really kept it light
hearted it's a movie that you can take
your family to I think yeah they say
like three questionably bad words like
bitch obviously zoology bitch zoology
bitch
zoology bitch 79 percent of rotten
tomato 797 I am B I am DB 91 percent
though of just normal ass people liked
it I don't know man I feel like it
should have a higher rating than that or
like like comparatively because such as
the rings I just wanted to make no sex
they only gave secondhand lions a fifty
whatever percent are you kidding me
that's blocking yeah check out our
review of secondhand lions on my
personal despicable Jumanji is a movie
that we watched here actually as a
family here
did you remember this experience were
you born I have no idea I don't remember
probably not at that it was the first
movie that really scared me he said
there was like spider there's spiders so
I walked down the hall to go to bed
after he watched Jumanji and I had to
come back in and get mom and dad's I
thought spiders were gonna come out of
the hallway there's so many remixed now
and so many things being put out there
that's like the original was so good why
are we gonna redo this and this is one
of the exceptions to the rule that it
like this is justice to the original
exactly I thought I was gonna like Maria
Oh God why but it it was good though I
don't know I can't I don't know we gotta
keep saying it because we were just I'm
just surprised that Ted would recommend
I think it was a blast I have no idea
what we're gonna see next week but we're
still gonna be here you see another
thing oh you do it yeah yeah we are
we'll see you all next week in our
childhood home as well zoology bitch
you